hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game uh from the super bet
chess classic 2021 uh it's fabiana
corona versus constantin lupulescu
another gentleman from romania we
already checked out two games uh by
uh by dieck uh i don't know uh you you
guys said i almost got it right so it's
either diet or diet but
i think it's direct so if it's diet uh
you know just uh
you know say say something in the
comments so i know for for the next
video that i'm making
uh but yeah here we have fabiana corona
versus constantine lupulescu
another very exciting game and uh well
it just uh ended so abruptly that it's
uh it's so so cool to see so
fabi with the white pieces opens with e4
we have e6 look plus goes for the french
defense we have d
for d5 and now knight to c3 we have
knight to f6
going for the classical variation uh and
now well you could
advance the pawn for example with some
like e5 then the knight goes back
here we have bishop to g5 just uh
pinning that knight here
we have d captures on e4 knight captures
and knight b to d7
so adding another defender to the knight
here we have knight to f3
and now h6 asking do you want to go back
or do you want to capture on f6
the absolute main line is just the
capture on f6 which is what fabi does
knight captures and now bishop to d3
continuing development we have knight
captures on e4 bishop captures and now
c5
and the black pretty much solved all of
his opening problems he
uh traded some pieces now he he got his
c5 moving attacks the center
and now he uh he still needs to develop
his pieces but so far everything is
working out nicely for him
and here although the pawn is attacked
twice fabi just moves the queen out of
the way he says queen to e2
and this is the the top move in the
position because uh
grabbing this while you could do it you
don't really get to keep the pawn
because after pawn captures you can
castle queen side
and now you can't defend the pawn uh e5
is not an option the knight covers that
and if you try bishop to c5 well you
instantly will
resign this because queen delivers check
and the bishop will just fall
so after queen to e2 we have queen to a5
check this is all very standard stuff
uh we have c3 defending and only now c
captures on d4
now the knight has to capture the c pawn
is pinned and now
bishop to e7 now lupulesco is also
preparing the castle
uh favi castle's queen side uh and he
says all right if you want you can grab
this a2 pawn and well it seems like upon
you
you dream of capturing because fab just
castle queenside
you don't really gain all that much
because here
queen to b5 check and what do you do now
uh there actually is one game where
where this happened uh bishop the d7 was
played and then you can just capture
here
and uh black has no good way of of
making use of all of these pieces in
front of the white king
and if you play something like king 2f8
and say i'm gonna take advantage of it
later on then you can just play rook
h to e1 and there's no good move for
black
you you don't really care about one
check you can just move the king
and then where does the queen go you
it's a pretty
pretty crazy position you can't develop
the bishop you can to really get this
work into the game you can't get this
work into the game
so it'll be very hard for black to play
this so instead we have
castles by lupulesco and now king to b1
this is not a prophylactic king to b1
this is just king b1 defending the pawn
or as it's already under attack so here
we have rook to d8
and now comes bishop the c2 and this is
what i find
really interesting about this line of uh
playing against the
the french with white is that you
already have an idea of what you want to
do
it's only move 15 and black has no
knights black traded off
both knights and now he has the bishop
pair but it's not
a bishop fair that's actually fully
operational or at least not yet
so here bishop to d7 black wants to of
course activate his bishops
and now get the other rook into the game
now queen e4 now we threaten
queen h7 king f8 and the queen to h8
checkmate so g6 must be played
and now h4 fabio wants to play h5 and
must open the position here and now what
you should
do here and this is probably the moment
that
everyone was wondering what's happening
here uh is
uh is this h5 move and h5 was not played
but
this seems to be the strongest but it's
it's looks so ugly that you don't want
to play it
point is uh white will play g4 attack
this pawn
but black doesn't really care black will
play bishop to c6 and he's just going to
trade everything off
so now you have to trade otherwise
you're going to lose a lot of material
here
so knight captures b captures and you're
perfectly
fine here uh you you can trade off a
pair of rooks you can bring the other
rook into the game you don't care about
the disc because the queen also uh
defends that pawn so it's not really a
problem
uh you easily get another very strong
defender over over to the king's side
so you you can play this however bishop
to a4 was played by lupulescu and while
this is still playable it
does offer fabi uh uh a bit more here
fabi plays a bishop captures on a4
queen captures and now h5 just you know
again threatening to bust open the
position g5
and now you have this position where
five needs uh needs some sort of a move
to get things going
uh and here well there are some very
nice ideas like maybe you could do a
rook
if you get the rook into the game you
could maybe uh strike
on the king side immediately with with
with a move like f4
fabi just uh plays uh and while i might
add in called blood uh queen captures on
b7 so he grabs this pawn
and he opens up the b file for the black
rooks to attack and it
it looks like a move that you don't play
but fabi is uh you know
world number two he's uh really good at
calculating lines
and if he says this is okay should be
okay the problem is this bishop is
hanging and you can't even sacrifice it
for some sort of an attack because
even if you go for something like rook
here queen captures there is
nothing you can do here if the queen was
on a5 maybe if you had some
queen captures in c3 action or something
but here you have to react to this
bishop uh
being attacked so here you should move
it to f6
just bishop f6 get the bishop over here
or even to f8 maybe
bishop to g7 later on but here bishop
the c5 was played
and now uh fabi's uh well uh
this makes it all that much easier for
fabi to just uh
keep uh keep his uh extra pawn so what
would you play here you know pause the
video and try to find
the the best way to exploit what was
just given to you
well i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding such a
elegant uh
such an elegant move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to c6
with a double attack here and now black
either trades or he has to play some
uh some uh well serious series of moves
like like queen to c4 to defend it but
then you get knights to b3
uh with a double attack on the bishop
here then okay the rook can come into
the
you can't play this rook because then we
can capture this rook so you have to
play this rook this rook remains
undeveloped
and now for example queen to f3 and the
game continues but
white set up with the dis pawn on c3 is
so strong that you don't have to worry
about
any any attacks here and uh it's it's
just much easier to play to play this
with white
you can simply bring a rook into the
game put some pressure here
it's just a very very nice position for
white however in the game
queen characters and c6 was played
lupulesco said all right
now you grab the pawn i'm gonna trade
down i can hold this being upon down
but that is uh well that's easier said
than done knight captures on c6
we have rook captures on d1 with check
rook captures and now bishop captures an
f2 so he grabs the pawn back
but now comes rook to d7 uh so material
is now completely equal but fabi has a
monster rook here on
on the seventh rank also uh if if uh
some of you are new to chess
uh a rook on the seventh is often called
a pig
or a hog even uh okay it's it's more of
a hog
uh maybe if it's you know doing business
on the age file and the seventh it's
it's mostly a pig
as it just gobbles up fawns uh so here
you have to play something but
there it's hard to figure out what to do
here uh you can't really move the rook
this is taken by the knight is taken by
the rook and the knight if you try
something like this to attack the knight
97 check just wins the rook
uh so it's hard to find the move here
for black so
what black does here is he uh plays
f6 and this is definitely one of those
positions where you don't want to play
f6
but there's no better move like you
could play some like a6 a5
it's very hard to find the move here for
black so f6 was played but now uh
the king really has no business uh being
in this game and
it it's all white from this point on
here fabi strikes uh
with knight to d8 now just threatening
to win this pawn
and uh how do you defend it the problem
is if you just push it let's say here
then knight to f7 comes and again what
do you play you can defend the h6 pawn
after you make a move doesn't really
matter just knight captures uh on h7
even if you defend it we can now capture
some other pawn doesn't really matter
which one because you are now
uh you walked into a discovery so we're
gonna start eliminating pawns
and black's position is is just
so bad that this is unplayable so
instead after this knight the d8 move
bishop to b6 was played
now he gives up the pawn uh for the idea
that if
knight captures then we can play rook to
e8 we can bring at least activate the
rook now the knight moves maybe we can
do some check
followed by rookie two maybe we grab a
pawn and so on however
fabi just goes knights the f7 and now he
says
i'm still gonna apply the same idea you
can to defend the h6 pawn so here we
have
rook to f8 and now fabi grabs knight
captures on h6
with check king to h8 and now just came
to c2
uh and there was in this position
unknown 28 that uh constantin lupulesco
resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
i just realized i just realized his name
is not centered so let me just fix that
for some reason it moved a little bit to
the right
that's weird so let me just
uh really quickly fix that
there we go why did why didn't you guys
say something
all right so that's nicely centralized
uh so here you resign uh because there's
nothing you can do the king is never
entering the game
uh you can't activate the rook the white
rook occupies the only open file on the
board
uh okay you could you could play this no
problem but then knight to f7 check
and again you lose the rook so again the
knight is your your your
worst enemy uh what you could do is
maybe you could try pushing some pawns
but it
it doesn't really work i if you try
something like uh
like e5 then we play g4 and then these
pawns are locked in here you can never
touch the f5 square
and now look at this you can just bring
your king over here
over to g6 and deliver rook to h7
checkmate
there are even ideas like these and if
you try something like
f5 well this does kind of make sense
then you lose the g5 pawn then for
example knight f7
check king jade knight captures here now
you're down two pawns now it's an easily
winning game for white
so a very very interesting and uh
it seems like completely out of nowhere
fabi got a
a a beautiful position and uh
i mean it's just so uh when things
really work out like okay this is all
fine fine
fine fine then we had this here the
castles by black was a new move i don't
know if i mentioned that but then all of
a sudden you have this queen to e4
and maybe this is playable for black but
it's so easy to play it for white that
after g6 i mean you just saw it
basically plays by itself
and you need the you know surgical
precision to just hold this with black
so that's
uh that's uh what you get usually when
you play
uh the french defense you know it's it
is very hard to play but uh
you know very very strong players fell
victim to it so
you know play it and see what happens so
yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it like i said we're gonna cover the
we're gonna check out the standings
maybe after round three because nothing
is really happening yet only two
decisive games were played the one that
we've already seen
uh by uh by the ack uh and uh by uh
here fabi uh versus lupulescu
so hope you guys enjoyed that uh i would
like to thank dave sales uh atila
kerestesi
sydney hamill harvick frost and benjamin
hofberg for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up any wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day